[Music]
joining me now is dr. Anthony Fauci
director of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases and
white house coronavirus task force
member all right dr. pouchy hannity told
me I got to do what he says he said that
for the nation and I know you've heard
this a lot but thank you for what you're
doing the time the energy the effort
that you're putting in and all the
members of the coronavirus task force
this is just I know because I get to
talk to a lot of you guys off-camera and
it's a non-stop life that you have and
for the foreseeable future so thank you
sir for that
you're very welcome it's a team effort
dr. pouchy the media seems to enjoy in
this very difficult time looking for the
tension between you and the president
and you gave an interview to Maureen
Dowd where you saw talked about you look
you have an you have a role the
president has his role but where do
things stand right now between you and
the president on the timeline and where
we are you know it's a back-and-forth
that the president clearly listens I
mean he has this aspirational goal of
hoping that we might be able to do it by
a certain date we talked him about that
we say we need to be flexible he
realizes that and he accepts that I mean
he doesn't want to give up his
aspirational goal but he's flexible
enough to say okay let's look at it on a
day-by-day basis we say and we will give
him data to inform the decision the more
we learn about what's out there
particularly in areas of the country
that don't have the big spikes like New
York and we talk about it we talk about
what that would do to inform our
decision but he's been very flexible
about it even though it looks like he's
made this absolute decision on something
he does have an open mind about it
dr. Fauci the new data that's coming in
I'm sure you've seen the wuhan study the
study coming out of Lombardi about the
ICU admissions and today andrew cuomo
bass
we said look we need 30,000 ventilators
is that the number in your estimation
correct given the new data and as you've
extrapolated out to the United States
out of Wuhan and Lombardi yeah but I
think the governor was saying I'm pretty
sure is that that's the total amount
that he would need you know and we'll
take it for his work worried about that
I mean he's you know quite frankly he's
really gotten hit with a really bad
situation and quite frankly I think he's
doing a very good job when he says
30,000 and he needs it we'll take him
for his word we obviously want to
estimate to see what he already has and
what the Delta is and what he'll need as
opposed the totality of the entire
period of time over the next couple of
months but the modeling that was that
was done on and he correct me if I'm
wrong is this by the Imperial College
and the American Hospital Association
and it was it was devastatingly
frightening and that was about the peak
that we have for ICU beds a peak for the
virus and the ICU beds that we'll need
but again looking at the Wuhan data
that's the latest data that we have
isn't aren't those new data points that
have to be used to inform our
decision-making on this critical issue
of overwhelming hospitals and how we
have to stop that so Mike White's a
long-winded question but are we updating
our modelling dr. fowey because this is
the critical question of overwhelming
our system you know Laura we always do
that we always update the model but the
one thing we have to be really careful
about and I think everybody who has been
involved in this who has experience
knows that models are only a good as the
assumptions that you put into the model
and sometimes there's a real great
degree of variability with those
assumptions so although we've really ate
the models continually we've got to be
careful that they don't always predict
exactly what we'll need that's just the
fact but that's a that's a pretty
important data point is it not because
we're seeing thankfully the mortality
rate decline as we test more people
that's still terrible but it
not as it perhaps as bad as that three
and four percent number that was
initially forecast so that that number
of ICU beds that are needed that's
really one of or if not one of the most
critical questions that are outstanding
and if it's wrong if the numbers are not
right then maybe that affects the
decision-making about when the country
can gradually get back to business
you're absolutely right Laura and that's
exactly right FEMA is working closely
with the state of New York to try and
figure out exactly what they'll need at
what time I mean if the totality is
thirty thousand what do they need now
next week the week after but you're
right those kind of models do help
inform us and doctor pouchy the news and
I was reading these studies today it's
clear that men are are more likely to
have serious health implications because
of this more likely to get the virus it
looks like including with hypertension
diabetes obesity heart disease all
factoring in the comorbidity rate once
people are actually admitted into the
into the hospital then it's a ICU and
yeah any idea of how and why that's
happening you know that's a great
question we do not know I mean we have
to be humble and say we're really not
sure it's a little bit puzzling this may
be some mitigating factors with men that
they have a greater incidence of some
underlying conditions perhaps we'll high
blood pressure
perhaps heart disease perhaps with
smoking and lung disease we don't know
we don't really know precisely but there
are some hints that they may have some
underlying factors that are a bit more
than in women
it looks like fifty seven percent of the
individuals who were admitted into the
icy or critical care in wuhan were
people with these underlying conditions
and a strong majority or men so that's
just that's another thing we'll figure
out eventually but dr. Fauci a lot of
people are messaging me during
the day about hydroxychloroquine and
other antivirals that are that are now
being prescribed by treating physicians
in the United States and beyond
so if heaven forbid something happened
to you you got a positive coronavirus
test and you you fell ill would you feel
comfortable taking one of these new
antivirals such as hydroxychloroquine
you know what I would do Laura there
there are a number of clinical trials
I'm a believer in a clinical trial of
course at the same time I'd want to help
myself
I'd want to get an answer as to what
really works or not so I would might
take one of those drugs but I would do
it within the auspices of a controlled
clinical trial I've always felt that way
and so you would but you would take one
of those drugs because they we are
getting certain positive results and
this is a wart this is war time right so
it's not it's not all buttoned down and
controlled why don't we do what we can
do with what we have I'm not so sure
Laura just to clarify that I would
necessarily take one of those drugs I
would take a drug that was on a clinical
trial some of those drugs that you're
mentioning are available within the
context of a clinical trial those same
drugs you can probably get from your
physician if they do an off-label use
because they are already approved for
other purposes like malaria and some
more to immune diseases but myself
personally I like to get some knowledge
out of it so if I had a situation where
I needed would drug I'd look around if
there was a clinical trial that would
give me access within the contours of a
clinical trial and dr. Koch II Americans
want facts and transparency but they
also want hope
so what hope can you give them tonight
you know I mean I did the hope that I
give is that that right now to just hang
on as best as you can
just please implement the
recommendations of the guidelines to be
able to protect yourself and those
around you avoid crowds do the things
that are on that list that we talked
about essentially every night but also
know as time goes by as we test
or drugs as we get better and better in
a vaccine you know I told you some time
ago that a vaccine is being developed it
still will be quite a while before we
have it but it is conceivable that this
may go into another season and if it
does it will bring us that much closer
to the possibility of having not only
drugs available but also a vaccine so
that's the hope for the future all right
dr. Fauci it's great to see you thanks
so much for coming on tonight good to be
with you Laura